Republicans in Alabama vote today in a
closely watched Senate primary President
Trump tweeted this morning Luther
strange has been shooting up in the
Alabama Alabama polls since my
endorsement finished the job vote today
for big Luther strange was appointed to
replace Senator Jeff Sessions when he
became Attorney General his challenger
former Alabama Chief Justice Roy Moore
is backed by the president's former
chief strategist Steve Bannon chip breed
is at a polling station in Birmingham
Alabama chip good morning
well good morning there is perhaps no
better example of the sharp divide in
the Republican Party than this race and
President Trump by taking sides is
risking an embarrassing political defeat
last night he sent Vice President Mike
Pence here in a final effort to try to
pull out a victory at six foot nine big
Luther strange has the support of the
vice president and the Republican
leadership including President Trump who
campaigned for strange over the weekend
Luthor strange
she knows the true source of America's
strength it's God it's family and it's
country but two sides of Trump
supporters were on display last night in
Alabama we did not come here to defied
Donald Trump we came here to praise and
honor him former White House chief
strategist Steve Bannon is campaigning
for arch-conservative Roy Moore a former
judge is it the elites in Washington DC
with their money or is it the people at
Obama with their muscle with more
leading in the polls the person who has
the most to lose may be President Trump
who suggested Friday he's already
prepared to regret endorsing strange and
I'll be honest I might have made a
mistake the president initially intended
to stay neutral but decided to support
strange in part because his agenda has
stalled and strange would be a reliable
vote in the Senate I'm all-in with the
president a more win would be a setback
for the president Moore said he would
vote no on the latest Republican health
care bill and has bragged about defying
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell Mitch
McConnell
needs to be replaced and he has the
enthusiastic support of much of the
president's conservative base I believe
in the second money has been flooding
into this state in the past few weeks
most of it is going to the establishment
candidate Luther Strange and most of
that money is coming from wealthy donors
and PACs they really want to win this
race and we will find out later today
who wins and that person will face off
against a Democrat in December charlie
chip thanks